So somebody asked this question and I posted the question and then I posted a little chart with it.
So how do I help heal from H. Pylori? A lot of people have H. Pylori issues.
I have a blog post on H. Pylori and please go to our blog and look at that blog post on H. Pylori.
But here's some examples. If you have an H. Pylori infection, you definitely have gastritis issues.
Decrease H. C. L. production of your stomach is the precursors to H. Pylori.
Remember, helicobacter pylori is part of our normal flora and it's what it's overgrowth and this takes over and then can go systemic.
Beyond the stomach and the intestinal tract that we really have issues.
So it is a bacteria, it's a gram negative bacterium. So it is an infection.
It is the cause of stomach ulcers and duodenal ulcers and esophageal ulcers.
The standard medical approach to H. Pylori is to give an antibiotic which will kill it if it's in the stomach.
If H. Pylori is one of those because it is part of the normal flora as well, it can invade antibiotics if it's systemic.
So if you have a systemic H. Pylori infection, it's affected your endothelial cells, your vascular endothelium, which is common with the systemic H. Pylori infection.
The systemic antibiotic use tends not really to deal with it because it can invade the antibiotics.
So it is something you need to work on with alternative methods.
You don't typically, I do not recommend you take antibiotics for H. Pylori infection.
Let's see, I have full-blown stomach ulcers that it might be appropriate to take antibiotics for a short period of time.
It's always accompanied by hypochloridria.
You're always going to have gastritis issues.
And the worst thing that you could possibly do for H. Pylori is to think that you have too much stomach acid and go on some protein pump inhibitor.
It will give you symptom relief, but it's going to cause the problem to become worse.
And that's how you end up moving H. Pylori systemically.
So you need to be taking HCl and digestive enzymes.
If you have a stomach ulcer and really damage to your stomach wall, you might not be able to tolerate that.
And you might have to just start with apple cider vinegar.
And I have that protocol on our blog post.
Or you have to start with this just deglycerized licorice supplementation and just start healing the stomach wall and then go to apple cider vinegar and then move to HCl and digestive enzymes.
But things like burberry, oregano, garlic, and some of these that are listed in this chart could be really helpful in healing.
The intestinal barrier support, of course, if you have cancer, you can't take an elglutamine.
But some of these other things you certainly can be taking with cancer.
So burberry, our Burberry clear pro is very effective for H. Pylori.
Our paraclear is also very effective for H. Pylori.